don't forget what you're forgetting  right nowadays they can't change it  because it's all about body positivity  they can look sexier in size 28. are you  saying lizzo's not a 10.  are you guys trying to get me canceled  see I'm not gonna I agree what you just  said because 90 of cosmetic surgery is  is by women women are trying to  touch possible men don't want to change  they're not accountable for themselves  they think that because because they're  a man you're going to be attracted to  them no like you can you can't be fat  you stay at home you're just playing  video games and you expect a woman to  want to [ __ ] you no she's not going to  want to [ __ ] you yeah but then she